BRIAN ARMSTRONG:
I'm Brian Armstrong.
If you see the screaming
cat on Gitter, that's me.
I did a Google
image search one day
and thought it was really
funny, so I picked it.
I also run Flutter Institute.
I have about four
times as many followers
on that Twitter account than
my personal Twitter account.
So it's kind of fun.
So let's talk about
sorting today.
Sorting is one of
those hard problems
that a lot of
really smart people
have spent a lot of hard
time figuring it out.
I did a quick
search, and Wikipedia
has 11 different algorithms for
sorting based on how big it is,
and how fast you want it, and
a bunch of different things
that you have to figure out if
you want to use a good sorting
algorithm.
So sorting in Dart, some smart
people did the work for us,
and it's a hybrid
of two algorithms.
If you have less than 33
elements in your list--
and someone did the math
to figure this out-- then
it uses an insertion
sort to be more optimal.
Otherwise, it uses what's called
a dual-pivot quicksort, which
I didn't actually know was a
thing until I did this talk.
The problem is, all
of these best case
are big-O n log n, which
just isn't quite fast enough.
Because we can do better.
We can make it big-O n,
because Dart is the future.
[LAUGHTER]
So I have some caveats.
First, you shouldn't
do this in real time.
Futures are asynchronous,
so we don't care.
The user shouldn't be waiting
on it for the app to respond
or anything.
So just put it in the
background and let it happen.
Second, I only designed
this to work for integers.
We could change that, but
right now, it's just simple.
And try to keep them
generally small.
Anything that gets in the
many tens of thousands
will probably not
be very useful.
So here, at long last,
is the algorithm.
You'll notice that we're
sorting everything,
and we're just waiting
for the duration.
So we'd start our Future,
and we'd delay it.
And I did a lot of
research to determine
the correct number
of milliseconds
to pad this with to
make this one work.
So we pad it with
10 milliseconds,
and then we just add
the integer to that.
So it just waits, and when
the Future finally completes,
then it adds them to the
list, and it adds them
to the list in
the correct order.
So this only sorts from smallest
to biggest, and that's OK.
And we use milliseconds, because
microseconds are just too fast.
[LAUGHTER]
We just keep it simple.
We don't care about when
the user gets it back,
because it's asynchronous.
But you'll notice we only
go over the list once.
So we've got big-O n.
[APPLAUSE]
That is kind of small.
So I actually made a demo.
You can run this in DartPad,
because it only has one
dependency, on dart:async.
And it's already been run, but
you can see, I went up to--
my largest number was 1,354.
It's item three on the list.
So if we run it, it takes a
minute, and then-- oh, man.
There you go.
There's my output.
And it sorts the list, big-O n.
Thank you very much.